vous l'avez sans doute remarqué si vous
êtes
usagé des transports en commun le trafic
est des transports scolaires des bus fil
bleu et car Rémy était perturbé dans
l'agglomération de Tours en cause une
grève suivi selon les syndicats par 80
conducteurs sur les 250 que compte
Keolis Touraine les grévistes réclament
des meilleures conditions de travail et
des augmentations de salaire Faustine
lunaux et Sarah
le piquet de grève a débuté des six
heures ce matin devant les grilles du
siège de Keolis Touraine à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps des conducteurs
receveurs de l'entreprise de transport
réclame une nouvelle hausse des salaires
pour faire face à l'inflation les
salariés à la fin du mois ont à peine
1300 euros par mois voilà le SMIC a
augmenté a fait un bon et nous on n'a
pas fait de bon on est resté au même
niveau et donc voilà les salariés ils en
peuvent plus quoi ils vivent plus et en
fait on demande à notre entreprise de
justement de comprendre notre notre
mal-être outre les salaires les
conducteurs parlent aussi d'une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail ces dernières années et demande
plus de protection
on est de plus en plus confronté à des
agressions verbales parfois physiques ça
c'est des choses qui n'existaient pas
nous il y a plus de 10 ans le directeur
du site se dit prête à discuter avec ses
salariés ce matin il est venu à leur
rencontre pour un échange qui a duré
près de deux heures mais qui n'a pour
l'instant pas sa disfait les grévistes à
partir du moment on a déjà donné six ou
8% d'augmentation sur l'année donner 10%
de plus 5 ou 10%, ça devient vraiment
particulièrement compliqué sur des
entreprises de transport ou nos marges
sont très très faibles donc c'est
particulièrement compliqué il y a des
choses qui se discutent qui se négocient
les conducteurs entendent poursuivre le
mouvement social jusqu'à l'obtention
d'un accord qu'il est satisfait